[Music]
on this tuesday night cautious optimism
about canada's trajectory
more canadians getting vaccinated could
mean more freedoms this summer
i am really hopeful plus quebec unveils
its roadmap
to reopening covid19 fears persist in
alberta's oil sands
it's really really cramped you're
basically back-to-back
how some workers allege dangerous
conditions
in the middle east calls for a ceasefire
tens of thousands left homeless
as both sides refuse to stand down
and the truth is out there when it gets
right in front of me it just disappears
why is the military finally admitting
ufos
can't be explained
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about vaccines in
canada millions more doses are arriving
and being administered and provinces
are quickly surpassing targets for
getting canadians vaccinated
that is not only protecting more people
from getting sick it is slowly boosting
the possibility of a less restrictive
summer
over the last five days about three
hundred and eighty thousand covid19
vaccine doses were given on average
each day about forty six percent of
canadians now have had at least one dose
about three point eight percent are
fully vaccinated
the federal government has said before
restrictions can
safely begin to be eased 75 percent of
canadians need their first dose and
20 percent must be fully vaccinated
chief public health officer dr teresa
tam says she is optimistic canada could
hit that target
in a matter of weeks we're not quite
there yet
but i am really hopeful because of how
fast some of the vaccines are going into
arms
it's imminently possible that in the
next weeks we're going to get to that 75
plus um 20
in alberta about 42 percent of people
now have
at least one dose but community spread
was so rampant there almost 700 people
are still gravely ill
hospital icus have never had more
patients
and in the province's oil sands camps
outbreaks are still spreading
hundreds of workers have become infected
four have died
the workers live and work in close
quarters and
some have told global news they felt
they were not properly protected from
the virus
heather urex west has tonight's top
story
given the risk were you surprised to see
that this was the
the layout for for lunches and meal
times at camp
100 um when i arrived on state the first
time
i was quite shocked this oil sands
contractor who we have chosen not to
identify
arrived at canadian natural resources
horizon mine site in late march
one of the thousands of trades people
brought in by the company
to help with a site maintenance project
known in the industry as
a turnaround three weeks later he says
he tested positive for covid19
he's not sure how he was infected but he
says there were times at
camp including mealtimes where he felt
particularly
vulnerable global news obtained two
photos of a trailer
four different workers say was used at
meal times during the turnaround period
at cnrl horizon
like you saw in the pictures they it's
really really cramped uh you're
basically back to back
so you're sitting there eating your
lunch you're exposing yourself to
everybody around you
a spokesperson with canadian natural
resources said the photos sent
by a worker to global news indicate to
us a room that was clearly closed and
not for use
this configuration does not have
sanitization stations
signage and require distancing in place
attached is a photo of a typical room
that was used for lunch breaks during
turn around
each lunch area is equipped with
sanitization supplies
and the tables are set at a distance of
six feet apart
but infectious diseases expert craig
jenny says with what we know about the
variants involved in this outbreak
there are risks associated with either
configuration
we do know that whether we term this in
aerosol or whether this is droplet
transmitted
it's moving through the air and and you
know i think people
fail to realize that simply being two
meters apart is not
a bulletproof solution cnrl says all of
its kovid19 protocols were approved by
alberta health services
ahs says because the company's dining
layout included tables closer than two
meters
the site was told to stagger meal times
so that only every other spot
or table was occupied heather urex west
global news
calgary quebec's premier has just laid
out a road map to reopening francois
lego
has some big goals for what he is
calling a summer of freedom
by the end of august if we reach our
goal
of 75 percent of the population over 12
with two doses mosque won't be mandatory
in most public
places that is pretty remarkable mike
armstrong
is following this from montreal mike
what is the science behind the decision
to begin easing restrictions
it's almost part science part sentiment
there's been real pressure on the
government to start loosening
restrictions
we've had some of the tightest rules in
north america since the beginning
we've also had some pretty sizable
protests so there's been pressure to
sort of let some of that pressure out
but also the science the numbers do show
that things here
are improving it's not something you see
on the streets but they're
feeling it in hospitals it is the waning
of the third wave of coven 19
and for emergency room doctors rebecca
apparently
wasn't that bad it was a breeze i mean
we
we were worried about it we made some
radical decisions early on and i think
that's really
shut down things that quebec is talking
about reopening
has a lot to do with its number of
hospitalizations tuesday it reported 484
coveted cases in hospital
other than a couple of days quebec
hasn't been that low solidly since
early october as for that third wave
peak it was the lowest of
any of the waves and compare that to
neighboring ontario
its third wave peak was its biggest
one factor was vaccinations and in
particular who was
targeted at risk groups went first then
older people
younger groups weren't a strain for the
health care system yes there was some
young people yes they were getting sick
but the numbers never reach any high
levels
quebec also put a focus on speeding up
lab tests
and rigorous contact tracing it also
tried to act quickly to stop outbreaks
by
shutting down schools and workplaces as
soon as an outbreak was detected
now quebec did do one thing no other
province or u.s state has tried
that curfew most of the province is
supposed to be home and
inside between 9 30 p.m and 5 a.m
it's a blanket measure but its impact
was really on one group
it kept young people from getting
together and spreading the virus
it's really hard to show the effect but
those are the population that because of
the curfew we didn't see outbreaks we
didn't see them coming to the emergency
all that much that curfew some of the
big news today francois lego announcing
that it will be
lifted effective next week may 28th also
the objective in quebec was to have at
least 75 percent of adults vaccinated
with
one dose by june 24th that's the
national holiday here in quebec
the premier is actually moving that
deadline not back but
up to june 15th so there is some
confidence there donna
all right mike armstrong in montreal
thank you
as canada gradually emerges from the
third wave public health officials worry
highly contagious variants could still
lead to more rapid spread
the big difference now is vaccines they
along with public health restrictions
are having an impact
canada's chief public health officer
says the number of active cases in
canada is down
25 percent now from the peak of the
third wave in april
as eric sorenson reports that's raising
hopes for an easier summer ahead
as canadians head outdoors for the
summer and as vaccinations rise
and covert numbers fall there is a sense
that change for the better is coming
these three friends have all been
vaccinated we think we still need to be
really careful
but there's sort of a hopefulness in the
air miu and jordan are keeping to a
small bubble
even as bigger gatherings push their
luck it scares me a little bit
but like i think we all know that there
are rules
we're certainly headed in the right
direction across most of the country
but we're still in the midst of a third
wave we're just
on our way out of it in a country as
large as canada the third wave has hit
provinces in different ways and at
different times
in the biggest provinces bc ontario and
quebec the third
wave peaked in april though in quebec it
was smaller than the second wave
in alberta manitoba and nova scotia the
third wave didn't spike until may
though in nova scotia it's the highest
numbers they've seen in the entire
pandemic
and what is clear nationally is that we
have had one two
three waves and that the third wave is
on its way down as we approach summer
but given what we've been through with
this pattern is there going to be a
fourth wave
in the months ahead whether there's
going to be a fourth wave that is
something
um you know that i think we we are
grappling with
around the world the so-called indian
variant and others that could yet
develop
are making health officials cautious
about declaring that a finish line is
within sight
last time we only got two thirds of the
way down
the curve and then with some
relaxation of restrictive measures we
went back up again but even with
variance of concern
infectious disease experts believe
vaccines make any fourth wave much less
threatening
yes you're going to start to see more
cases but the number of people
hospitalized will be proportionately
much
less it's a load that our hospitals
normally deal with in a you know in a
fall late fall or winter basis and it's
not something you need to close the
community down for
some epidemiologists see a type of
normal returning this summer
and lasting and with things opening up
with vigor and permanently probably in
august and beyond
i expect schools to be open in september
and i expect every day to be better than
the previous day so the end is in sight
at least in this country thanks to
vaccines many experts think a fourth
wave will not
bring massive lockdowns so there is
reason to feel some optimism
i see a light at the end of the tunnel
eric sorensen global news toronto
there is more clarity tonight for
canadians who got the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine as their first dose
canada's chief public health officer
says if canadians want a second dose of
astrazeneca they can get one if they
give informed consent
for those who don't want astrazeneca as
a second dose it's likely
they'll be able to get pfizer or moderna
though research into mixing doses
is still underway in india the number of
active new cases is starting to decline
but deaths are still rising and
hospitals
are still swamped today the deaths of
more than 4 000 people were reported a
new
single day record india has now
surpassed 25 million cases
many states continue to have limited
vaccine supply even though india
is home to the world's biggest vaccine
producer today the serum institute of
india said
we have never exported vaccines at the
cost of the people in india
it says it plans to scale up
manufacturing and prioritize domestic
distribution
but its deliveries to the un-backed
initiative known as kovacs
will be stalled until the end of the
year that is a significant setback to a
global efforts to supply vaccines
to low-income countries tensions remain
high in the middle east tonight there
were huge protests in the west bank in
support of palestinians
and the mounting loss of civilian lives
in jerusalem demonstrators were met with
gunfire
it was the first time arab israelis held
a general strike like this in decades
in the west bank palestinians declared a
day of rage israeli police killed at
least three people during these protests
israel is carrying out more airstrikes
on gaza tonight and hamas
is firing more rockets towards israel on
the ground
in gaza life is a nightmare our redmond
shannon spoke with gazans
living in the line of fire
craters and debris the aftermath of
another series of air strikes in gaza
this man says he and his family got a
phone call to evacuate before their
apartment building was destroyed in a
bombing
we have been living like in a horrible
movie nordine jamal and his family
temporarily evacuated their apartment
after a false alarm on sunday my sister
like
she keeps clinging to me each night
because she is scared of the israeli
pumping
i i see horrible i see a horroring scene
in her eyes
it's unbearable the un says 52
000 people have now been displaced in
gaza many taking refuge in
u.n run schools like these in some cases
warned them
they've protected their life but now
they're homeless and need to completely
rebuild their life
many essential services have been hit
gason officials saying their only covet
19
testing lab is out of service we use the
10 war
when when two countries with equal
powers are fighting
we are not equal with the occupation
forces
palestinians in the west bank and
israeli arabs observed a general strike
tuesday in solidarity with gaza but the
rocket attacks continued into israel too
two workers from thailand killed on a
farm not far from the gazan border
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu visited troops at an airbase
tuesday
maintaining the air strikes will
continue at least
until the attacks on israel stop prime
minister justin trudeau has joined the
biden administration
in calling for a ceasefire i think
it's important to note that we are
engaged
in quiet but very intensive diplomacy
late on tuesday there were some
optimistic news reports out of israel
about a possible ceasefire deal later
this week
redmond shannon global news london
the path to a planet with far less
pollution
coming up a bold road map to net zero
from an agency that used to ensure a
steady supply of oil
there is a landmark new assessment from
the organization that has spent decades
securing oil supplies around the world
the international energy agency now says
investing in new oil
gas and coal projects must stop if the
world is going to reach net zero
emissions
by 2050 and it has a road map on how to
get there
it says the energy sector which produces
about 75 percent of greenhouse gas
emissions
must undergo a complete transformation
of how we produce
transport and consume energy that means
an end to new oil and gas field
development
and no new coal-fired power plants an
end to the sale of new internal
combustion engine passenger cars by 2035
an immediate and massive deployment of
all available clean and efficient
energy technologies and rapidly scaling
up solar and wind
making them the dominant energy source
by 2050
an unparalleled increase in global
energy investments
rising to more than six trillion dollars
by the end of this decade
that could create millions of jobs in
the clean energy sector
the international energy agency is not
an environmental organization
it was formed after the oil crises of
the 1970s
and its reports and forecasts are
frequently cited
by energy companies and investors as a
basis for long-term planning
ahead the potential of mrna vaccines
goes far beyond protecting us from covet
19.
canada has to rely on covet vaccines
made in other countries
today the federal government announced
it is investing 200 million dollars in
an ontario company to expand its plant
and make
mrna vaccines here though it won't be
complete until 2024.
mrna vaccines the ones pfizer and
moderna make
are built on decades of research but had
never been successfully developed
until covid19 emerged it is a huge
scientific breakthrough
and as jamie morocco reports it has
other potential applications
in a lab in vancouver scientists at
acuitos therapeutics have been tinkering
with
mrna technology helping to craft the
pfizer and viantech covid19 vaccine
we provide a delivery technology
tiny tiny lipid spheres
that protect the messenger rna a
blueprint for your cells
messenger or mrna instructs them to make
a specific protein found in a virus
in sars-co v2 for example it's a spike
ultimately
after an injection your immune system
should recognize it and build antibodies
fighting the virus off i think it is a
real game changer scott halperin the
director of the canadian center for
vaccinology says what
makes mrna so useful is its versatility
very easily you can change the genetic
code and
and make a protein from a different
virus
applying this to the flu hiv zika or
even
cancer a disease the world health
organization estimates
killed close to 10 million people last
year alone
cancers also express proteins that are
abnormal
that we're trying to evoke an immune
response to in the body
and so mrna technology could be
applicable there back in vancouver
thomas madden says his company has
already seen some successes combating
rabies
certainly there's excitement about
trying to apply the mrna vaccine
technology
to some of these more challenging
diseases
but first scientists say we need more
information noting the need for
long-term studies and data into the
longevity of mrna vaccine protections
donna jamie morocco in toronto thanks
unidentified but not unimportant next
why the u.s military is taking ufos
seriously
there's a change happening in the way
one of life's biggest mysteries is being
handled
the u.s military now acknowledges some
strange objects seen
flying through the sky cannot be
explained we call them ufos the pentagon
calls them unidentified aerial phenomena
and as david aiken explains a report on
what's known and
not known about them will soon be given
to congress
day after day for nearly two years u.s
navy pilots would encounter
this unidentified aerial phenomena or
uap while flying off the coast of
florida
i don't see an exhaust pool no exhaust
plumes
no markings no wings but caught on a u.s
navy camera in 2014
and verified this year by the pentagon
well there's no question that this is
really attracting a lot of attention
uh the videos um can be interpreted in a
lot of ways we simply don't have enough
information or
all the information to really evaluate
them
but the experiences that are reported by
the pilots
are something else entirely indeed
that's just what a former u.s
president said monday on a late night
talk show there's footage
and records of objects in the skies
that we don't know exactly what they are
we can't explain
uh how they moved their trajectory
and these sightings are more common than
you might think in 2020 the year of the
pandemic
canadians reported more than twelve
hundred ufo sightings
that's almost three a day a nearly fifty
percent increase
over the number of sightings in 2019.
people perhaps were
uh spending more time outside their
homes looking up rather than inside
venues being able to see the sky a
little bit more
spending more time to appreciate what's
up there but it is accounts from
reliable sources like those us navy
pilots
that have authorities taking uaps and
ufos
more seriously than ever before there
was four of us
in the airplanes literally watching this
thing for roughly about five minutes so
your mind tries to make sense of it i'm
going to categorize this as
maybe a helicopter or maybe a drone
and when it disappeared i mean it was
just so i go like this and it's climbing
still
when it gets right in front of me it
just disappears
next month u.s national security
agencies will provide
more information about what's out there
with some
unclassified reports delivered to the
u.s
congress david aiken global news ottawa
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's year
canada is this herd of
clearly identifiable deer near courtney
bc
how do you compliment a deer you've
phone over her
that's all i got tonight thanks for
watching see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves
bye-bye
you